nous n'avons pas d'après et si nous annulons
le premier aperçu, la presse va
sentir le sang et nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre de
perdre plus d'argent du tout d'accord
pensez-vous que je devrais bien faire nous avons embauché
une doublure utilisons la doublure
maintenant  Megan écoutez MP s'il vous plaît pour l'amour
de Dieu écoutez notre acteur de rêve parfait
ne va pas frapper à cette porte aigle ici les
gars Ben est-ce que je ronfle
puis-je vous parler une seconde ouais
quoi de neuf avez-vous trouvé un autre acteur hein d'
accord bien Mike est disponible oui  mon nouveau, je
pensais qu'il faisait la chose pourquoi il a
quitté ma coopérative, c'est-à-dire que je pourrais être viré
Oh quoi le Mike c'est généralement les deux Mike
est rentré à la maison méné oui Jake oh mon Dieu comment
tu connais mon entraîneur
nous partageons un vagin je pense qu'il a gagné  mec
mm-hm comment sais-tu parce qu'il m'a dit que tu avais
gagné
Jake Jake oui fils m'a demandé si tu vends
bien des billets est-ce qu'il a l'air je pourrais voir
vendre une merde de billets et ils
ne me demandent pas si les critiques de théâtre aiment
des critiques de théâtre ou ils veulent l'
espionner hey Les  allongez-vous sur son
visage tout pour une raison bien ils
pourraient venir ce soir je vais l'appeler
et le découvrir